[Music]
Answering the question from earlier Leah
Why am I here?
]
me
[music]
That's good
Victor's here.
Graduation Ceremony 0Hey, everyone,
her relatives live in the area
towards
Katohana.  It's a story, but
the commander-in-chief of the chindai is the name of my mother,
Lieutenant General Hurikan, so
all au die from overwork.Evacuate your
relatives
quickly.They will fall into the hands of the Kioka army in less than a
month.Ikuta Stroke
What does that mean?
Lieutenant General Lee Hum's East Station Chirai is
still fighting with all its might Even
before a defeatist like you
knew,
hey,
hey, there's nothing to say back.
I'm relieved that you showed up properly.
In the future, you have the
power to defend, but not the power to
attack.The former emperor is serious about going to war.
The
eldest daughter with a good temperament needs a medal of passing first place
This time, the youngest child of the Remyung family seems to be a rival
, and it's never been better than 8 o'clock
.
Because I want to finish with
I wish I could somehow be that kind of person
[music]
Lief Sem
is the Marshal
I wonder if it's Roma Becker
This child looks like a partner's water spirit
Big Sem
That's grass
Thank you very much I don't feel comfortable
being called by my last name  Because there is no
Toride  Please
, Paro, who takes your word for it
Death change is a satellite change car It's as you say I'm embarrassed to
take the exam for the third time Soroga
Why are you here? Did you pass too
?
Pond partner is Fusei 2
He is also a high school student Doha
If you know a bottle that can be closed
, I think you
will be very happy to tell me What kind of
introduction  But if you sell one of the best old warlord brands, it's
closed milk?
Maker
's name Sorok is a personal name
Far from being a maker's date, I'm talking about my fatherless story
.
Please call me
K-kun.
Go to another institution, Ikuta, it's okay, it
's a
lot of
handshakes
.
Let's go home Hey,
come on in
Everyone was just introducing themselves
I'll take a Remio
After this, go beyond the wind spirit
Please take care of me It's a difficult exam, but can we do our best together?
Look at this girl, it
goes without saying that she's above 3 shares of her partner
.
I won't let you do that
Red-kun is on
Masuo and you're a clumsy kid Don't forget this name
Lemio's youngest child I
'm good at remembering people's names
Can I call you Ma-kun?
I don't need a hunter
You were found guilty in a face trial The
charges are straight out It's a
cosmetic agent Um, the scriptures of temple teachings should
name all stations
Uh, you're just saying that and you're even
in an
inter-religious bar.
She's the only one who can call me that.
I'm Hello. She's
Becker.I'm aiming to be a commander of the regular soldiers.I have
five younger brothers in my family
.  It's a lie to guarantee
that it's been introduced five times.
I
'm sure it's just before 21 My friend Marsh
Just when I forced the wind musketeer into the enemy
's line Do you remember the donation?
Thank you, Mr. Tori,
you were playing military shogi,
right?
Besides, blindfolded shogi is better if it's played by soldiers
.
Even the perspectives in the regional divisions
don't always work as planned, right? What
soldiers need is the imagination to draw out the big picture from fragmented information.
There's someone there It's
okay I
don't think I'm an exam student I was
emigrated This two
, I don't think there are any general passengers on board
Ikuta
Hi Sakura I have
6 more years until I'm edible I'll go to cram
school exactly 15 years or so I
guess nobody  I haven't heard anything in the shadow of your strike zone
I'm heading to the electricity with only the bare minimum of luggage
Follow the sailor's instructions and get into the life-saving problem mina
Whose color is this
?
Let's go to the market a
little more to the right,
Mr. Wecke goes to the left, yeah, yeah, yeah
[music]
First of all, I won't do that 2
If she can still see you,
shine with the high beam
Ikuta is dangerous
Tanuma 4
[music]
It
's
okay, you'll
die in a box.
Your
Highness, please give me a schedule to worship in the morning like this.
Wasn't
this actually a
princess?
She warmed the sulfur?
Say, please, pardon, pardon,
your goodwill, I thank you from the
bottom of my heart,
Sonata
No, I called myself Toshiko's good habit 6 Ah, it was already eight years ago that a
stranger visited your house on the occasion of the visit to Kinjo.
Do you remember
that time, His Highness had just become four with a sound, and
you were counting?
Without the ring at 0 o'clock, I was at a
point where I couldn't be sure.
We're
out of the token to see
what's going on.  If it's really warm, I
'll shave off my hair and give it back Oh,
I'm sorry, but the princess is dressed like a town.
I think it's best not to pry into the other person,
but you
'll get stuck in a quagmire,
but you looked up, right?
It's just as important as the life of my comrades and Sapphi
.
Even so
, I'm hungry Beep I don't know how much it costs, but if you're in
high school, you can see the eastern border of the United States to the west,
which
means that your home is here in
Kioka Republic, or are we in an
enemy country?
Now
that it's come to this, I think it's wise to keep everyone on the same page,
but there
are two options.
I
think I'm
overly optimistic that my safety will be guaranteed even in Koryo. There are people
among them who can be used as diplomatic
bargaining tools.  In
short,
even if you become a prisoner of war here, it's not a business negotiation.
Shut up,
princess.
Even if you become Iikura, the
impossible won't become possible
.
Please forgive me for
this time
I jumped into the sea during the
storm.  Ikuta
Kojika must have been the one who wouldn't get mad even if the sarcasm entered.
I didn't think so, after all, I thought I had
given up a long time ago, but hey, it's a
disrespectful way of saying it, but
the behavior of the world is toshishiro, and that's
right.
So,
how much skill are you
looking for?  Even if I try to talk about it, it's
impossible, but
today I had a lot of things, but
I
decided on black vinegar
[music]
No, I don't,
ran
, but it
's true that 4's yelling won't change anything.I'd like you to think for a while
whether you want to cross the border on your own or just settle
for nothing.It's just
as the
world says.
I think it's fine to spend the first day or two of the new year thinking about things
[music]
This is
Hokke.  There
are a lot of Kusumi barrels in front of me.It's
for aiming as far away as possible
.
]
Amikko It's
much more
necessary for a humane life than that kind of thing The
voice is
something like
naval funds It's a
punchy one Once you
get used to it, it's comfortable
Come on
[Music]
Amazing
I was able to get on at Mu
Eh,
this  Can you sleep on it?
It's the sky of A. I
remember that it caused serious damage to the atmosphere.
Who's there?
Yeah, yeah, everyone wake up Something
crossed the line
[music]
You can always take what you want with your preparations When we don't go home, do
n't hesitate to choose to be a prisoner of war
Movement e 9 e
Something over there now If there is someone
, raise both hands and come out 5th place
52 is 10
[Music]
Thank you now
Ikuta Sorrow Ward called
Ikenuma